[Music]
we learned recently from the atlantic
magazine which was a new experience
because we don't normally learn things
from the atlantic but we did learn that
kamala harris maintains an
enemies list journalists who make her
mad
harris politico reported quote tracks
political players and reporters whom she
thinks don't fully understand or
appreciate her life experience her life
experience like
growing up in canada that's a life
experience she doesn't want to talk
about
but nothing makes her angrier than when
people question her lived experience and
which is euphemism for her unsupported
opinions
visiting the southern border with mexico
back in june one nbc reporter found that
out the hard way
do you have any plans to visit the
border at some point
you know we are going to the border
we've been to the border
so this whole this whole this whole
thing about the border we've been to the
border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't i don't
understand the point that you're making
well the point of course was that you
haven't been to the border
but she didn't understand it
and she was equally baffled and enraged
a few days later when a reporter at
univision
asked the same question watch
i've said i'm going to go to the border
and when are you going to the border
vice president administration has asked
i'm not finished i've said i'm going to
the border
imagine waking up next to that i'm not
finished
miranda divine is a columnist with the
new york post and we're happy to have
with us tonight so miranda
i got to thank you so this is not
someone who was pulled off the street to
answer
questions from nbc and univision both of
which are slavishly loyal to the obama
to the by administration this is the
vice president united states who's got a
whole pr team around her
what do you make of responses like that
hi tucker well i mean she's obviously
been
prepped to within an inch of her life
she's had extensive media training
on this particular question because the
minute
that joe biden gave her that poison
chalice of being
the administration's border czar that
was the question and when she took
three months to get to the border
obviously she was going to be asked it
and for her bizarre and brittle and
very insecure responses to that obvious
question
which you know lester holt could not
have been more gentle when he asked that
question it was just that
when she outright said i've been to the
border and he just stunned
said well actually you haven't that she
then came out with an even more bizarre
response about having not been to europe
and
she couldn't understand of course she
understood and the problem
with kamela harris is that she's come up
in california
where the media is just unquestioningly
showering her with praise she expects
the media to do that
all she doesn't expect challenging
questions and she's quite affronted by
it you see
her attitude she gets very chilly and
she feels that it's a mortal offense
that she's being asked a question
that doesn't allow her to shine and
skate through
these difficult uh ideas like perhaps
that there's a problem at the border
and i i just think that she's not match
fit
and i don't see how she can be because
i guess she's never exercised those
muscles before because all she's ever
had is accolades
i think that's such a wise point she
acts like she's been betrayed by a
friend when's the media ask your
questions
is interesting random vine thank you for
your analysis
thanks checker